although it's blurry this seems to be
kit harington and emilia clark in
costume as jon snow and daenerys
targaryen standing near each other in a
tent
clark appears to be wearing a jacket on
backwards indicating that this is a
rehearsal and that the cameras are not
rolling at the moment
it seems that just like azra hai who had
to draw his sword into his wife's living
heart in order to create lightbringer
john will have to do the same azera
hides a legendary figure in the fate of
the lord of light
thousands of years ago during the long
night azrakai forged his sword
lightbringer which he used to defeat the
darkness of the great utter this came at
a price however as in order to unleash
the sword's true powers he had to plunge
it into the heart of his loving wife
a prophecy that was mentioned multiple
times throughout the show foretells that
azraj will be reborn as the prince that
was promised
i already made a video regarding which
character might be this prophesied
savior but john son of ice and fire
seems more and more to be the lord's
chosen if jon's notion is the prince
that was promised it means that daenerys
is probably going to die
according to prophecy these are
indicators of the coming of azra hai
after a long summer when the stars bleed
and the cold breath of darkness falls
heavy on the world he has rahi shall be
born again amid smoke and salt
he shall wake dragons out of stone he
shall draw from the fire burning sword
libringer
he will also be born of the line of
heirs ii and ryla and according to
regard targaryen he's also the song of
ice and fire
in the tv show the first time he
stumbled upon ezra high's theory was the
scene in which stannis spilled some
magic sword that was forged by plunging
a blade through the burning statue of
the maiden that decepted dragonstone
after melisandre convinced stanis that
he is azra hai
that ceremony was meant to be a rebirth
of azra hai the burning statues of the
seven provided the smoke and the waves
on the shores of dragonstone provided
salt
but however stennis was not born from
the line of mandarin cinderella and also
while stannis's sword shined thanks to
mel sanjay's magic it gave off no heat
meaning that the sword could not
possibly be lightbringer now let's see
if jon snow truly is azor ahai
after long summers rachel will be reborn
amid smoke and soul prophet
says this could point on jon's
resurrection he was reborn after he was
stabbed to death by night's watch
traders
so here we have rebirth but what about
the part of smog and salt
well in my opinion the wall could
represent the salt since in the books
it's told that the wall contains the
salt quoting from the books
the door separately brushed against the
top of bran's head and drop of water
fell on him and ran slowly down his nose
it was strangely warm and salty as a
tear now let's try to solve the smoke
part since the prophecy says that azra
hai will be reborn amid smoke and salt
well the smoke part also came true do
you remember that melisandre while she
performed resurrection ritual to bring
jon back to life do you remember the mel
sanjaya called locks of john's hair and
tossed the curls into the flames after
which we saw the smoke
this is only one part of the prophecy
but it's not the only part that matches
with prophecy
it's said that the prince that was
promised should have the blood of the
dragon should be born of the line of the
mad king airs targaryen and really
targaryen with giannis as his son of
rhaegar
therefore and darys are jon's
grandmother and grandfather
before i proceed let me just highlight
that the showrunners know from george rr
martin himself who as rahaya is
and therefore we should pay attention to
every single detail no matter how small
it could be
with that being said let's get back to
the final episode of season 6.
beside revealing that leona stark is
jon's mother they also revealed that
john was born under a bleeding star
which fulfills the part of the prophecy
which says the prince that was promised
will be born under a bleeding star
as we could see eddard stark entered the
tower joy with a bloodied sword dawn the
ancestral sword which was forged from a
fallen star
does dawn covered in blood counts yeah i
think it does
it's also important to highlight a few
other facts like for an example when
melisandre looks into her fire to see
azra high melsanji only see things
related to irigion or snow
second thing that i would highlight is
john's dream that he dreamed in the
books
the dream in which he fights the others
with a red sword burning in his hand
long story short both dany and john are
tied to the other high prophecy which
includes a historic legend of a hero
sacrificing his love to save the world
from the long night
melisandre told daenerys that she has a
role to play in the prophecy as does
john snow
this is bantis
the prince who has promised will bring
the dawn i believe you have a role to
play
as does another the king in the north
jon snow daenerys role in the long night
is most likely her eventual sacrifice
and death
basically after a huge amount of
casualties and upon realizing that their
chance to survive the long night is
small
jam will realize that he has to do
something horrible to end the long night
in order to save all instant people from
a certain death john will have to kill
daenerys in the final episodes of the
show
however let's get a little bit back in
the season 8 premiere devil resurfaced a
book about the long night that gilly was
reading in the previous season
in the season 7 premiere show pointed
out that the boogie picked up and began
reading was a book about the long night
while the exact part she was reading was
about the prophecy of azra hai and they
did it purposely
sam already found out about john's shoe
parentage in season 7 which basically
confirms that gianni is a song of ice
and fire
however sam will also learn about jon's
death and resurrection in the final
season
and it's quite possible that it will
it's sam to proclaim jon the prince that
was promised a hero that will will
the flaming sword to stand against the
others and if he falls the world falls
with him
in the third episode of the sixth season
mel sanji already told jon that he made
the prince who was promised but samuel
nam tried to convince jon that he is in
fact the lord's chosen
this would mean that jon snow as the
prince of his promise will defeat the
night king and save westeros but in
order to do so john will have to
sacrifice daenerys who will at this
point be his wife and mother of their
child
however while this theory would most
certainly match with george rr martin's
announced bittersweet ending i still
believe that a theory of mine will come
true
as a matter of fact i believe this
leaked photo confirms it it's the
nearest becoming the night's queen
the night's queen is an unseen woman in
game of thrones a legendary figure known
in the seven kingdoms and among the free
folk
according to legend the lord commander
of the night's watch found in the
haunted forest a cold woman with bright
blue eyes
he took her to the other side of the
wall and declared himself as the night's
king
earlier in game of thrones we've learned
that the leader of the white walkers the
night king is able to create other white
walkers but only
that human being is a pure blooded and
says born this means that the night's
king could turn the nerves into one of
them since danny is pure blooded and
says born daughter of hungarius and
queen raela targaryen
the only way for the living side to end
the long night is to either defeat them
which would be insanely hard or to make
a pact the spect of ice and fire would
include daenerys
have you ever wondered why is the night
king even coming south why was he
preparing an army all those years with
which he started marching south at the
moment of daenerys's arrival at westeros
i was wondering about that ever since
the sixth season ended and they came to
a conclusion that daenerys arrival at
westeros is the reason of the night
king's preparations the reason of his
march south and is the reason of every
single death that the seven kingdoms is
going to confront
daenerys could have on the throne as
soon as she arrived at westeros if she
wanted to
as jean stated dany did not take the
throne yet only because many innocent
people would have died
if she had decided to storm king's
landing kill for me
they're hard to miss but still
i need your help not to defeat cersei
you could storm king's landing tomorrow
and the city would fall
hell we almost took it and we didn't
even have dragons almost
but you haven't stormed king's landing
why not
the only reason i can see is you don't
want to kill thousands of innocent
people
it's the fastest way to win the war but
you won't do it
which means at the very least
you're better than cersei still that
doesn't explain why i need you
she did not attack the capital because
she did not want to cause death upon
millions of innocent people and she will
not ever sit on the iron throne because
she will decide to give up her life so
those people including her child could
live
the nearest visions are foreshadowing
that then he could diesel even the iron
throne and sit on it but it also
foreshadows that she will realize that
she will not be able to sit on the same
since she will have to give up on it for
the greater good
she will accept a pact with the night
king in order to end the long night
daenerys will become the night screen
where upon herself and the night king
will go beyond the wall and rule over it
as a form of peace agreement between the
living and the dead
beside daenerys's visions as i've
already said multiple times
dany's arrival at westeros and the night
king's preparations send his march to
the south fits perfectly in timeline
i don't think it's coincidence that all
of those years the night king was
preparing and gathering huge army with
which he started marching south at the
same time of daniel's arrival at
westeros
also the fact that the show included
multiple scenes that are proving that
the night king can create other white
walkers only that human being is pure
blooded and says born has to be
foreshadowing something huge
to that at the fact that daenerys is in
cess-borne daughter of kangaroos and
queen rael a targaryen and this theory
has a huge chance of coming true
not only that this theory would be one
of the greatest surprises that show
runners could pull out but it would also
fit perfectly with the bittersweet
ending that george r martin announced
daenerys will in this theory die in the
hands of jon snow only to later open her
eyes as the night's queen in the hands
of the night king
if you would like to know all details
about this the night screen theory of
mine feel free to check out a video by
the name the night king is coming for
daenerys
long story short this sleek photo goes
in favor to two possible endings of the
dragon queen
the nearest will leader die in the hands
of the prince that was promised jon snow
who will have to drag his sword into his
wife's living heart in order to create
lightbringer
or will die in the hands of jon only to
shortly after open her eyes as the
night's queen in the hands of the night
king
whatever the case the nurse will have to
sacrifice her life for the greater good
just as every true queen will do for the
good of her people